I'm gonna open this up to a few fan
questions here that I got first one
comes from Brian
Glenn olds from Vancouver British
Columbia Vesta I love Latin America
that's amazing
Brian asks Hugh I heard that on x-men
Wolverine hmm you had specially designed
lifts put in your shoes so you would
appear taller than one of your co-stars
is this true or just a silly fact it's
it's true I I did ah next question but
but it was a story reason that
everything in that movie was about story
in character sorry advancing it you know
yeah hey youtubers is Charlie so huge
news we found out the John wig director
is going to be doing Deadpool too after
all in Ryan Reynolds did this interview
where he revealed a whole bunch of funny
stuff going all the way back to bull
Vereen Origins Deadpool so here we go
they just confirmed that the director of
John wick will actually be doing the
Deadpool 2 movie earlier this year he
was mentioned as like the top pick so I
did a video about it like hey you know
John wig is a movie that does a lot of
the same things as the Deadpool
character does so it made a lot of sense
that they would look to him so I'm
really excited about that but obviously
the Deadpool 2 movie is further off
they're finalizing the script hopefully
they'll lock down their cable Domino and
any other big supporting characters from
the comics they're gonna do but they're
not going to start shooting for what
like it's going to be a while before we
actually see teasers but the really cool
thing is that I talked a little bit
about the big x-men universe reboot
Deadpool is largely
insulated from that creatively now
obviously Fox wants everything to be in
the same universe so they do want a
shared continuity but because Deadpool
is so successful they're just going to
let it do its own thing for now so if
you're like freaking out about Deadpool
being rebooted completely no that's not
the case they'll just work everything in
however they can so that eventually it's
all connected
but without having to completely
sideline the Deadpool movie and they've
already started talking about the third
movie basically introducing x-force as
cables team so rather than start with
New Mutants which is kind of how it
started in the comics like Deadpool's
first appearance was in a New Mutants
comic book where cable was training his
team but because they talked about doing
a New Mutants movie they might just do
x-force inside the dead
movies so exports and New Mutants are
very connected but functionally you can
call them different teams is just that
in the comics the original x-force team
was put together from characters from
the original New Mutants team so that's
further off that's just like the big
twist that they said that they're
working on for Deadpool 3 and we
wouldn't see that for at least another
like three maybe four years depending on
how soon they get working on Deadpool 2
so that's all really exciting but Ryan
Reynolds recently did like this puff
piece at GQ where like their tiny hands
stroked his ego and he revealed some
really funny things about the Deadpool
character going back to the Deadpool
movie and back to Deadpool in Wolverine
Origins so the really funny thing some
of you might be surprised by this maybe
not surprised is that while they were
making that Wolverine Origins movie it
was during the writers strike in
Hollywood
meaning they weren't able to hire
writers to write dialogue for him so
Ryan Reynolds came up with his own
dialogue for that movie so a lot of you
will say hey you know that was actually
a pretty crappy Deadpool movie so does
that mean that Ryan Reynolds is
responsible for Deadpool being so crap
in that that is actually not true
so his dialogue was all his but the
stuff they did with the character was
all the studio so like the fact that
they turned him into like this amalgam
Weapon X with you know swords that came
out of his arms he had nothing to do
with that in fact last year at comic-con
when they were promoting the most recent
Deadpool movie he said that he had a
very big I told you so moment with the
studio when people backlashed against
that when all the fans everybody was
like this is garbage he no he just
pointed at the studio and was like see I
told you so but you did it anyway
and people hated it so it's just funny
to see him having a version of that
conversation behind the scenes like I
told you it was gonna be garbage but you
did it anyway and it ended up being
garbage yeah I just enjoy performing
their own stunts yes do you do all your
own acting if there's sex scenes I do
them yes that's where the craft is yeah
it's a key to a good marriage did you
guys get any notes from the studio - so
Eddie's mouth shut make lasers shoot
from his eyes you know I didn't but I
thought it'd be a great idea as a story
it totally makes sense part of a set
always hundred percent do you ever age
not since 2009 or gorgeous so it makes
me hopeful for Deadpool - given Ryan
Reynolds has a little more creative
control than he's had in the past but as
you know Tim Miller left Deadpool
- just because of creative differences
behind the scenes so now we have the
John wick director coming in Reynolds
did say that he was really disappointed
to see Tim Miller leave because it was
such an awesome time making the first
movie in fact another really cool Ryan
Reynolds fact is that he paid the
writers out of his own pocket because
the studio wouldn't pay them to come
onto the film set and help them rework
the script while they were shooting it
so like normally you know when a script
doesn't work and they're out shooting
scenes they bring in a writer to help
rework things and make the scene better
but the studio like Fox studio did not
want to pay the writers of the Deadpool
movie extra money to come out to the set
to try and make the movie better so Ryan
Reynolds paid the writers out of his own
pocket that's how much he wanted the
movie to be good so anybody that's super
worried the Tim Miller left the project
in the junkie XL the composer left don't
worry it's okay it's still going to be
an awesome movie it's just when people
hear our directors leaving a project
usually one either they got fired
because they're terrible director or to
the studio wanted to do something crazy
and they didn't agree with it but this
isn't either one of those things like
Tim Miller is a great director he's
already moved on to another project and
now they're getting ready for wheels up
to get the Deadpool movie going again so
let me know what you guys think about
the history of Deadpool it's just you
know funny how like the studio tried to
do their own thing
during Wolverine Origins Ryan Reynolds
was naturally really upset but didn't
have a lot of power couldn't really do
anything about it then after about five
years of spinning his wheels trying to
get the Deadpool movie made with Tim
Miller leaked the test footage at Comic
Con that was Comic Con 2014 then they
got a little bit of money made a really
badass movie and now it's like the
biggest thing ever at BOC Vegas rated
our superhero movie of all time let
alone rated our movie in general I think
it's actually the highest-grossing rated
R movie of any kind of movie of all time
but because we're so close to the end of
the year I wouldn't be surprised if they
drop like a funny teaser when they
reveal who cable and Domino are just
like some visual teaser about Deadpool -
something funny
and I know a lot of people have like a
specific cable actor that they want but
I'm totally cool with whoever they go
with as long as they kind of you know
visually fit the bill and they form a
really awesome comedic duo with Deadpool
now keep in mind the Deadpool is the
funny one Cable is the guy who reacts to
Deadpool so you don't need like a giant
Arnold Schwarzenegger guy that tells his
own jokes like cable doesn't tell his
own jokes
Deadpool is the guy with the
over-the-top non-stop jokes but as we
learn more about x-force and how they're
going to be integrated into the Deadpool
movie I'll do more videos about that
right now it's really preliminary
they've only talked about doing New
Mutants they haven't said much about
exports only that they want to introduce
them during that third Deadpool movie so
be sure to subscribe for more Deadpool
there'll be a whole bunch of Deadpool
before the end of the year and what's
going to happen next this weekend is
I'll probably do some more Young Justice
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff that's going on so there is any
like specific comic book stuff that you
guys want me to do like I mean actual
comic books let me know in the comments
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about the
big x-men universe reboot of Fox and you
can click here to learn about the
Inhumans TV show at Marvel thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you